hello everyone and welcome to what is
probably the shortest game i will ever
show on this channel
or rather i think we had a game that
featured all four moves but
those were four different moves this
here however are not
uh it's a game from the final round of
the magnus carlsen invitational the
preliminaries
uh magnus calls him versus hikaru
nakamura and well let me just
show you what happened and then uh you
guys can uh sure
share some opinion on what you guys
think
actually happened here uh so e4 e5
uh nothing out of the ordinary here and
now magnus challenges icaru to the bong
cloud king to e2 and yes this is now
officially called the bomb cloud
uh even uh if you you know try playing
on chess.com it will offer you
uh the name of the opening as the bong
cloud
we have king to e7 hikaru replies with a
counter bomb cloud and now magnus goes
back
king to e1 king the e8 and now you might
think okay now the
now the game will just continue with
castles not having any castling
privileges
sorry with players not having castling
privileges but nope uh king e2 king is
seven we have king to e1
and now king back to e8 we have king to
e to king to e7
and it was in this position that the
players agreed to a draw
or rather the game ends in a three-fold
repetition
so i i really thought that three-fold
repetition was impossible here as
maybe it was against the tournament
rules but i couldn't find any such rules
but even if it even if it is against the
rules that this
was not uh and agreed to draw this is
actually a three-fold repetition and
the uh you know the interface uh
says it's a draw if the position is
repeated three times so
uh um i don't know why the these guys
decided to play the out
the way they did because i know both of
them enjoy playing chess immensely so
it doesn't really make sense to do
something like this uh maybe they just
wanted to have an
extra rest for for tomorrow because both
of them are now qualified
for for the main event for the knockout
phase uh maybe they did they didn't want
to
show their preparation for for you know
uh the
the other players that they might face
in the later parts of the tournament but
i have no idea i mean if it's already
not up the uh the standings if there's
no way for you to drop
out i i don't think there was a way for
hikaru to drop out so
uh i i don't know it really seems weird
so i'm
more than uh more than interested in
hearing your opinion on this
why would why would they do this i mean
why everyone expect
everyone is waiting for this matchup and
they want to see some
premium chess and then you end it like
this that's that's not the way to do it
so i i'm very sad i don't know
i don't know what do you guys think
about this and digest it i'm not even
gonna do the outro for this video as
i i am very sad uh so yeah see you soon
guys